please welcome our friend Christine  Abigail  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  these are real balloons that's so nice I  have a balloon thingy at home so I blew  these up before I came I ran out of  ribbon so this is just string I found  okay sure  okay this is a clip okay clip it on I'll  just clip it yeah over here so it's not  in your in your face the whole time yeah  I uh wait you have a balloon thingy and  you have a helium dispenser at home why  why not yeah okay good Hollywood man  yeah it goes I brought you this women in  film hat that I  and I also I also I just go to me like  look just I look like a sad boy manchild  and I I brought you an old baby monitor  an old baby monitor it doesn't have a  plug but okay just I just found crap in  my garage I don't know a lot of party  today and I appreciate it thank you  thank you so much  you